humans are very bad at coming up with
random things random think truly random
so for instance there's an experiment
where try to work out the exact way they
did it there's an experiment where
there's um there's two two black boxes
okay
and they both display three sets of
heads or tails so it'll be like head
tail tail or head head tail or tail tail
tail or so on okay now both boxes
display a series of those it changes
every five seconds once generated by a
computer and once generated by a human
being okay so there's a human being
sitting there typing and then there's
another one which is a computer just
making them up and generating
automatically okay and now you do this
test and it's really funny because you
would think ah humans are creative and
we were imaginative right we can come up
with something that's random but we
can't our brains aren't aren't they
don't lack structure and now that we can
come up with something truly random so
if you do this long enough okay what
will happen is the one that's on the
computer
it'll tree very evenly split um for
instance you get head head head and tail
tail tail equally as often as hair her
tail and all the other combinations
whereas a human will be skewed in one
direction there'll be one that we like
don't forget or they'll do it repeatedly
or they're like wait which ones didn't
do I remember anyway so it's actually
very do got to do some like this on your
own you start doing things that are all
the same once you've got your data you
can change it however you please you may
want to do some things like I've made
this bigger so that you guys can see it
but you may even want to view and up
free some panes particularly the top row
because that way you can scroll up and
down and you'll still have the fields
showing which is kind of useful all
right that's always sort of handy to do
now what are we actually going to do
with this well I want to revise some of
your skills and knowledge to do with
manipulating spreadsheet formulas we're
going to try and put it into well can we
make a decision support system to do in
this okay so if you remember how who
remembers how to make an if statement in
Excel we did formulas with this really
simple ones
okay okay that's right I I sort of
glossed over very quickly but it's
really simple let's have a go at this
okay what I want us to do is put a an
extra column over here okay and let's
call it say hmm status okay now what
we're going to do is try and calculate
off of all of these things is a person
overweight or are they under way are
they about right or whatever okay now
before we get to that before we know
that you can sort of you may have been
able to tell from the next question and
a really easy way of working out whether
someone is overweight or underweight or
you know in generally a right spot is
the body mass index okay
so let's remember this one's pretty
simple how do we put in or calculate a
BMI how do we do Emma okay good so
what's on the top it's going to be your
weight right so there I've got the way
of just this person in this room okay
and then I have to divide by what
remember yeah the height squared okay
clearly this thing okay
however this height is in centimeters I
asked you to put in centimeters because
usually people say you know I'm this
tall and they say it's a roof but we
need the height for BMI we need to be in
centimeters right so I'm going to open a
bracket and I can't just take this by
itself and square that I want to get
from centimeters to meters so I buy 100
all right so there's the denominator
that's the height and now I have to
square that little piece so if you
remember for an index you use this
little symbol here it's called a hat
okay so listen I'll divided by height in
meters squared all right so there's a B
amount and once you've done this you
remember the beauty of Excel is that
this formula because it has relative
references in it you can take that
little corner
a peg and drag it down you can take that
formula and apply it to all the cells
below okay you got some value yes
interesting okay no that's interesting
right now what you may like to do is now
actually go and get some real
information about okay good go on you
know Google and search up BMI and what's
an acceptable range like a person who
has a BMI of twenty point one seven what
is that funny what does it classify that
is it um you know average overweight or
bass or you know in the other direction
okay go set that up
okay now while you're searching that out
he's only gonna do it I I don't actually
know what the numbers are but I'm going
to show you what to do with them in a
simplified form okay give me a second of
your attention so I can set you up and
then you guys can actually finish this
task now here's where the if statements
come in okay I want to say something
about this person now because I don't
actually know the numbers and I know
there's several different parts I'm just
going to simplify it to say you're fat
or you're Thea okay
very I'm pissy sorry sorry to that girls
are in this but it just make it simple
for me when I'm working out what this
status part will be okay so what I want
to do is start a formula say equals
okay and it's called an if statement
because it's it's providing condition
like say this if you're this say this if
you're that okay so I'm going to start
and saying if okay you can see that
Excel recognizes this is a formula
that's why you get this order quickly
here now before that goes away have a
look at what this says okay it checks
whether a condition is met and returns
one day is true and another value if
false so it's just going one of two ways
it's a dichotomy okay so I'm going to
open a bracket and that tells me what
kinds of things what kind of information
I'm going to put into this formula to
make it work okay so once I grew up in
the bracket this comes up it says I know
it's a bit small but you'll see it on
your screens hopefully logical test
comma value of true color value if false
and then it ends the bracket okay so
this logical test here is about these
values and applying some kind of logic
some kind of condition like an
inequality to it right so for instance
let's look at my BMI okay I'm just going
to say all right if your BMI is less
than 20 that makes him feel I don't know
what that actually means but that'll do
so this is my logical test okay it's a
simple one your ones will actually have
the proper numbers for BMI
okay but this will do it for me to go
into the next part the value if this
test
is true put a copy right you can see
Excel is very helpfully bolding the the
actual part of the equation the formula
that you're up to so what did I want
this to say if this is true if it's less
than 20 I want to say okay you're a thin
person if you want to input text you do
have to put it between quote marks okay
it doesn't have to be quote marks this
value of true could be equal to some
other cell or some other formula or
anything like that as you'll see in a
minute about to the value if false so if
you're not then then you're going to be
that okay so there we go all right now
when I press ENTER what are you
expecting to happen the formula will
disappear just like the formula for BMI
disappeared and will be replaced with
the answer to the formula right which I
hope he is right okay now again because
we've done some formula magic yeah that
that Walker guy free fat okay the happy
way take your own peg in the corner drag
it down okay so by the looks of it
actually a local it is one of the
wonderful individuals who's you know
only they we don't have any fat people
so good on you okay anyway babe go you
can see what's going on okay now as you
know this is actually not as complicated
as a real-world all right this is very
very simplified okay so what if we
wanted not just one or another but
different kinds of conditions like under
way severely underweight average and so
on okay now there are lots of ways to
skin a cat okay there is more than one
way to do this I want to try and
introduce a way which just uses the same
tool it's going to look a little complex
but it's it's little more difficult than
what we just did okay
so let's say if you're less than 20 okay
you're thin but if you're not thin that
doesn't automatically make you fat okay
so let's introduce a class in here
called average okay average so if you're
less than 20 we still want to say thin
okay but if it's not true if you're not
less than 20 I don't want to go straight
to fat I want to have two new options so
for two new options I'm going to say if
and start again okay now I'm going to
add in another bracket here because you
can see what I've got is the same kind
of structure if and then one two three
right but within this third thing I've
got a whole nother if thing and you can
see that the green brackets are trying
to tell you all right this is one little
compartment on its own right now what do
I put in here okay well I'm going to go
the same way so let's say that if you're
less than 20 or thin if you're less than
say 30 30 let's call that average
okay so under 20 film now under 30
average and now if you're not under 30
you're above 30 and we'll call that fat
okay
now I'll leave this up here for a second
just so you can make sure one of the
things about computers right is that
they'll interpret what we say very very
precisely okay so if you've got a comma
or a quote mark or a bracket in the
wrong spot or if it's not there you'll
often have really serious problems with
your father okay so just make sure
you've got it right and now let's see
what happens okay so he's average now
why he doesn't fit into that last
condition anymore okay he's not under 20
but he is under 30 okay so now I'm going
to take this formula and replace all
these other ones
all right so you can see now I've still
got some thin people I've still got some
fat people and I have three people who
are between 20 and 30 and that's why
they're classed as average okay now
that's sort of all I'm going to say at
the moment I want you guys now to say
well okay I've got some more information
here I also know I think I know this
person's age yeah this person's age it
should make sense to you that a
five-year-old who's you know sixty kilos
and a 15 year old who has 60 kilos are
not both average right so I'm gonna
leave it to you to think about how could
I use actually information how can I use
this kind of logic right to make a
decision support system that says go get
some exercise or go on a diet or join
The Biggest Loser or whatever you like
so as a decision support system we're
trying to take data and help people make
a choice okay so I'll let you guys do
that make all different ones you can add
in another column if you like and put in
populate that without it whatever data
you like so you can help these are these
these poor people over here make some
decisions okay